17 starts out with part a find this
integral now you'll notice and most
people were okay with this from the
outset that there's ends instead of X's
most people were ok with this with one
little issue and I'll show you what that
is in a second I'm integrating with
respect to M so 3 M Squared I'm going to
increase the index to 3 and then I'm
going to divide by that new index so 3 M
cubed over 3 and then you have your
result which will simplify in a second
I'll do the same thing with this 8 M so
I'm going to increase that index by 1
and then divide by that new index and
then this next part here is a plus 1 now
a lot of you instinctively because
you're so used to integrating with
respect to X you wrote down plus X
because a plus 1 usually turns into a
plus X however we're integrating with
respect to M that's the variable that
we're interested in so it should be plus
M and then lastly we have a constant of
integration so we can tidy this up just
a teeny bit by canceling there's an M
cubed there's a 4m squared and then the
terms that you saw the form now when
we're determining this particular
integral I'm like we saw before with our
negative indices and our fractions this
particular integral is not written so
it's set up to make integration easy you
have to manipulate a little bit and then
go for the rules that you know how to
use so I'm going to write this
completely in index form without any
square root signs you know this 4y cubed
which the square root is being taken
over the equivalent of rinette square
root sign is the power or the index of
our 1/2 so if I use my index laws now
having that 4y cubed on the inside and
then all of that is raised the power of
1/2 I can write that as number 1 for a
power of 1/2
well what's 4 to the power of 1/2 that's
the square root of 4 that's why we
introduced this index of 1/2 in the
first place so 4 to the power of 1/2 is
just 2 it's the square root of 4 y cubed
to the power of 1/2 is y to the power of
3 multiplied by 1/2 that's one of the
index laws which we learn all the way
back
yes you know eight nine really so that's
going to be Y to the power of three on
to integrating with respect to Y so from
here you just need to be cautious in
your application of the regular standard
rule that you use for integrating this
for starters that too is just going to
hang out the front and then with the Y I
am going to increase its index and then
divide by that new index that looks
messy we're going to simplify it in a
second but before I do don't forget it's
an indefinite integral so it has a
constant of integration
all right fractions on fractions that
looks disgusting how do we fix it well
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
multiply the numerator and the
denominator both by two on the numerator
it just gives you for y to the power of
five on two divided by now because I'm
multiplying by two it cancels the on two
that's in the denominator so you just
get five and then plus C so there's the
answer if you wanted and often it is
helpful you can write this answer in the
form that the question was provided to
you so there was none of this you know
on to like fractional indices in the
question that was posed to us so if I
wanted to restore this to looking like a
square root I would say that this could
be written as four-fifths and it's the
square root of Y to the power 5 plus C
or you could even write that as that's
also equivalent to 4 over 5 the square
root of Y to the 5 if I take out a
factor of Y 2 power 4 you get Y squared
square root of y plus C okay let's have
a look at Part C now find a period of
function for dy DX equals 6 to the power
of 2x now a lot of people got twisted in
turns here because of number one the
base is not a so it's obviously more
difficult to deal with and also you've
got that 2x in the power which means
you've got to use reverse chain rule as
well so this can be a bit of a mess now
what I'm going to suggest is the easiest
way to ever think about this is to
rewrite this 6 that have
to X let's rewrite this derivative using
our index laws 6 the power to X is the
same as 6 squared to the power of X this
is 36 to the power of X now even though
these are equivalent I actually would
contend that this is easier to work with
because you don't have to think too much
about inside derivatives outside
derivatives remembering that if you were
differentiating something like say 5 to
the power of X e to the X is the one
that differentiates into itself every
other base like 3 or 4 or 5 or a hundred
it differentiates into 5 to the X log 5
in other words you multiply by log of
whatever base you happen to be starting
with now since that's the way
differentiation works to integrate I'm
going to divide by log of whatever the
base happens to be so therefore the
primitive function y is going to be the
integral of 36 to the X with respect to
X it becomes 36 to the X but instead of
multiplying by log 36 I'm going to
divide by log 36 plus my constant since
they said find a primitive function then
I'm gonna say a primitive is I'm just
going to choose C equals zero so that's
36 to the X on log 36 now this is how to
do it if you don't want to have to worry
and fuss about with how the chain rule
works but I will show you how the chain
rule works I should take the reverse
chain rule and you can see I'll show you
the comparison that you do end up
getting the same solution so let's go
straight from here if I were saying Y is
the integral of 6 to the 2x DX
okay so in this case here what I need to
do is I need to say okay I'm going to
divide by the log of the base but I'm
also going to have to divide by the
inside derivative hmm that's a lot to
take in so firstly you just get that 6
to the 2x you can see just like before
this 36 to the X and the 36 to the X on
the next line that
doesn't go anywhere but then what you
divide by it is number one log of that
base which in this case is six and
number two you divide by the inside
derivative the inside function is 2x the
inside derivative is 2 and then you
course add your constant now let me show
you how this is the same as what we got
before I'm six to the power of 2x well
that's the same 6 squared to the power
of X that we saw in our very first line
of working and then lastly 2 log 6 is
actually equivalent to using our log
Wars log of 6 squared and then we have
our constant and hopefully you can see
in both cases you've got this 6 squared
to the power of X which gives you this
and then you've got this log of 6
squared which is the same as this log of
36 so whichever way you ain't you got
the same answer but you might have found
it easy if you didn't have to worry
about reverse chain rule because a lot
of people just frankly forgot when they
were doing this question all right Part
D now you get this integral here and it
looks like a terrible mess but if we
simplify a little bit before we start
integrating again it'll be quite
manageable so let's have a go this
integral what I need to do with it is to
divide everything on the numerator by
the denominator and then I get three
separate terms I integrate them one at a
time so 3x to the 6 divided by X to the
4 that will just leave me with 3x
squared minus X to the 5 so there's the
minus X to the 5 divided by X to the 4
leaves me with just a single X and then
lastly this 2x cubed divided by X to the
4 there are more X's on the denominator
than the numerator so that leaves me
with 2 X to the negative 1 DX now I
reflexively wrote this in index form
because usually that's the way the
integration works easier for us but
actually that last term there the 2x to
the negative 1 you might recognize it
more easily if you saw it as 2 over X
what's the integral of 2 over X well
when we get there it's going to be to of
log
X you can see that the one over X if I
just factor out that 2 that becomes log
X and now I've just got double of them
and it is worth noting I should move
this guy over because not just X it's
the absolute value of X and if you'd
like I'll I'll link to a explanation of
why it's the absolute value of X you can
see that result on your reference sheet
but you might wonder why it is so I can
explain that in another place it takes a
bit of time let's have a dough at the
rest of the parts of the integrand T
being integrated 3x squared it
integrates into X cubed that minus X
becomes minus x squared on to because I
increase the index divided by that int X
and lastly I have a constant of
integration
since it was an indefinite integral